Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new witcher season 2 netflix video they
released a teaser trailer a little while ago
showing off some of the new monsters they were
bringing into season 2 and some of the cast first
look preview so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing an amazon giveaway
all you have to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions for the witcher season 2
on the video so we'll just start with the footage
first then the cast previews then i'll talk about
the jason momoa witcher stuff i know everyone
would love to see jason momoa show up as a witcher
in the netflix universe but the teaser trailer
they released a little while ago had previews of
a couple new monsters that they're doing in season
two this one is believed to be the three crones
of crookback bog they actually show up during a
mission in the witcher 3 but you don't actually
see the crones themselves they're part of a legend
the legend goes that in foul times when plague or
famine steals our harvest we must beg the ladies
for help if they deem fit they will hear our pleas
and knock back fortune's foul blows these are
the instructions for how you beg for help from
the ladies quote-unquote as they call them find a
child young and innocent and take it to crook back
bog search out the ladies shrine that is where the
trail of treats begins this is starting to sound
familiar set the child off the trail and it shall
follow its sweet track and find the good ladies
the child will never want for anything ever again
for the ladies are kind and generous standing
before their shrine pronounce your request and the
good ladies will hear for they see all that takes
place in their domain if you made the offering as
it must be done your supplication will be heard so
if it wasn't clear it's implied that they eat the
children that you sacrifice to them then this is
the other new monster that they're introducing in
season two it's too hard to tell just from looking
at this clawed hand but it looks like it just
clawed someone's eye out and it's just dragging it
along here just covered in dirt and grass the only
other monster that they talked about doing during
season 2 was the lesson so it's possible that they
include that in season 2. the geralt teaser that
they released just shows off his new armor which
i think is a huge design upgrade over the season
1 witcher armor there were a lot of armors that
got redesigned for season 2. i know you're asking
about the nilfgaardian's armor yes the showrunner
said that they would fix that for season 2.
the full synopsis for season 2 kind of tells you
where he's at at the beginning of season 2 episode
1. it just reads convinced that Yennefer's life
was lost at the battle of sadden geralt of rivia
brings princess cirilla to the safest place
he knows his childhood home of care morehen
while the continents kings elves humans and
demons strive for supremacy outside its walls
he must protect the girl from something far more
dangerous the mysterious power which she possesses
inside which is a reference to her elder blood
then obviously the new preview of Ciri is from
cameron where geralt vesamir the other witchers
will be training her i'll talk about the other
witchers that they're introducing during season
2 in a second but this is her smack dab in the
middle of that if you played the games geralt has
a dream of Ciri the beginning of witcher 3 with
her training as a child that's a pretty good
approximation of what this will be like at the
beginning of season 2 episode 1 as that official
season 2 synopsis implies the reason why they're
training her is to help her control her power
and better prepare her for the wars to come
but this is long before the wild hunt shows
up long before the prophecy of her elder blood
comes true in the coming of the white frost that's
all stuff that you get into during the witcher 3.
there's still a lot of battles to fight
before that happens you still have her
father emperor mir you have vilgefortz who winds
up becoming a pretty big villain in the series
we also have a first look at some footage that
they were filming of some of the nilfgaardian
mages including stregabor so this is strigabor
and vilgafortz just walking around in the middle
of one of the episodes i'll talk about them in
a second when i talk about yennefer's character
because most of her scenes at the beginning of
the season will be dealing with those mages up
in nilfgaard the funny rhyming quote that they
came up with for geralt just reads his emotional
shield can ward off any charmer but his trusted
sword hill wield will be matched with new armor
i think part of the joke of this is you're
supposed to read these like jess gears coming up
with him because he's the person that creates all
the songs on the show everyone toss all the coins
to your witcher the quote for Ciri just reads her
tearful goodbyes on a most violent night now this
child of surprise is preparing to fight then the
yennefer preview is of her literally in chains
pretty much after the battle of sodom hill that's
because she was captured by the nilfgaardians
after this conflict and is forced to serve emperor
amir which is why she and geralt and syria are
separated for a good amount of the season at
the beginning they're not going to do multiple
timelines or anything like that they'll probably
be some flashbacks to explain how she wound up
with the nilfgaardians so we'll probably just
bounce back and forth between yennefer scenes
up closer to nilfgaard with the mages and
then geraltine series scenes of her training
but it'll all be happening at the same time with
maybe a few flashbacks to explain how they wound
up where they are there were some scenes of them
filming geralt and Yennefer together looking like
they had been reunited but i'm assuming because
they don't film the episodes in a linear fashion
that this is happening way later during the
season Yennefer's quote that they came up
with just reads she used her full might and the
battlefield burned then she vanished from sight
but yen will return the big deal with jason momoa
joining the witcher netflix if you didn't see my
video from a while ago is that he's actually in
talks to play the very first witcher during one
of the spin-off series that they're doing called
witcher blood origin it's basically just the story
of the very first witcher so it's going to be a
six episode miniseries and they're going to be
doing things like that big spin-off series of the
main witcher netflix series in the future too like
a witcher netflix cinematic universe i would love
to see jason momoa play a witcher it's only six
episodes so i think it'd be pretty easy for him
to squeeze it in his schedule because he is so
busy doing apple series doing the aquaman movies
but he posted this art to his instagram calling
out henry cavill on his instagram so if he's
putting his justice league brother on blast about
joining him in the witcher universe it sounds
like it's actually pretty close to happening
the order of the witchers in all the different
witcher schools were actually created after the
conjunction of the spheres so you have all these
different monsters crossing into the planet from
other planets they needed special warriors
to fight those monsters so the mages actually
developed the witcher potions for the mutations
that turned them into witchers the werewolves did
we raise our swords against them have we laid
this burden on others one so-called witches
stray children taught the ways of foul sorcery
their bodies mutated through blasphemous ritual
incentified monsters though they could not
distinguish good from evil the flicker of
humanity long extinguished within them so whatever
they get into in this witcher blood origin series
i'm assuming they'll also get into the origin of
the witcher mutation potions like the trial of
the grasses the other new witchers that they're
introducing during season two will seem familiar
if you played the games or you read the books
obviously but one of them is cone he's a witcher
from the school of the griffin who also helps
train Ciri in sword combat they're doing lambert
who's another younger more recent witcher from the
school the wolf where geralt is from they're also
doing eskel who's another witcher from the school
of the wolf who's been geralt's friend since
childhood they actually went through training in
the trial of the grasses together so they have a
lot more history and i know a lot of people would
have loved to see mark hamill play vesamir because
he was talking about on his twitter account
a while ago he wasn't familiar with who the
character was he didn't know anything about the
witcher series but he was like i should definitely
play this character but i guess for whatever
reason the scheduling just didn't work out so
they wound up casting kim bonya from killing eve
so he will be playing vesamir during season 2.
obviously one of the bigger characters they're
actually doing a witcher movie and anime movie
that i believe is called the nightmare of the wolf
which is all about vesemir when he was younger
they didn't say when they're going to release that
but like i said they're developing many different
witcher netflix projects not just the main series
with henry cavill geralt Ciri and yennefer that's
just the main story the other really big character
that they're doing from the books it'll actually
seem familiar is novellan from the last wish story
a grain of truth he's a cursed man who's kind of
like the beast from beauty in the beast it's a
very similar type of story but with a darker twist
on it he's being played by get this tormund giants
bane from game of thrones that's right he spends
all of his time on that series boasting about the
things that he does with bears only to come to
the witcher netflix to turn into a bear himself
there's a ton of other new characters too but
basically season 2 will essentially be adapting
the story from blood of elves with a little bit
of stuff that they're circling back around
for like the last wish novella and character
and even though i mentioned emperor amir and velga
forts being kind of like antagonists in the series
the real villain of season two arguably a
blood of elves the book they're adapting is
riots so they haven't announced who's playing
him but it's possible that they just combined
his character with cahir's character from
season one and they're just going to use him
in that role during season two and he becomes a
much bigger villain than he was during season one
they've been a couple breaks in their filming
schedule just because of issues with the virus
and having to take things slowly but i believe
the plan is to still release the witcher season
2 episodes by the end of next year once we get a
trailer for the witcher movie and for this other
witcher spin-off series blood origin i'll start
doing videos for that stuff too but everyone
let me know in the comments if you have any big
questions i will do more witcher netflix videos
as they start to ramp up we'll probably see some
footage sometime early spring next year at least
because henry cavill also has the justice league
snyder cut coming out next spring they'll probably
try to build on the synergy of that just because
so many people will be thinking about henry cavill
around that period like okay let's dump some
witcher netflix footage give them all the henry
cavill that they can handle and for those of you
that were asking earlier today apparently there
was an issue with youtube being down around
the world nobody was able to watch any videos
hopefully it's fixed by the time i post this
video but as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all the videos
when i post them and there are links for all
my social accounts twitter facebook instagram all
that stuff down in the description my mandalorian
season 2 episode 3 video is going to post on
friday while you wait for everything click
here for all my witcher season 2 netflix videos
and click here for my full mandalorian season 2
episode 2 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!